the most important question that you'll
be asked to any interview
is do you have any questions you
definitely
should keep watching and we'll discuss
i'm richard and this is richard undata
so when you ask an interviewer a
question there are a few different
things that you can accomplish
first of all you do need to ask some
questions in order to demonstrate to the
interviewer that you're engaged you're
interested
and that you're thinking about the right
things but above all else
asking questions helps protect your
interests too
there are tons of organizations out
there that you really don't want to work
for
and there's some red flags that you
should sniff out
but more generally data departments can
vary substantially
and you do want to find out if you're
going to be in a working environment
that you're genuinely going to enjoy so
i'm going to give you
seven different questions that i
recommend asking your data science job
interviewer
these questions are going to make you
look good and they're going to help you
figure out if the job is right for you
in the first place
but before i do that please subscribe to
my channel if you haven't already
and also take just half a second of your
time to smash the like button to this
video because it really does help my
content reach a larger audience
also in the description of this video
i'll have a link to my patreon account
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over there it would mean the
world to me
alright so one of the first questions
you want to ask is
how does data science provide value to
the organization
or maybe putting that a different way
how exactly do data science projects
align with business goals on one hand
this is something that people who are
just fresh out of school
don't necessarily ask as much a lot of
those types honestly
are hammers in search of a nail where
the hammer in this case
is things that they learned while they
were in school if that's you
or even if you're somebody with more
experience
then asking this kind of question will
communicate to the interviewer
that you're somebody who's focused on
the bigger picture and it's not only
that
but it is a great question that should
give you some valuable information about
the organization's overall strategy
their structure
and the specific data department it'll
tell you if data science is all part of
a bigger
more strategic plan or the company is
just trying to get in on the hype
now for this one you do have to have
done a little homework
obviously at a bare minimum you want to
have researched the company a little bit
and know what it is exactly that they do
but then hopefully on their website
or earlier in the interview process you
at least get some kind of idea about
where they're going strategically
as well as how they differentiate
themselves from their competitors
connect those dots all the way down to
where your role is going to fit in
it'll be pretty informative the second
question you want to ask is
what technologies does the department
use for data analysis and data science
now there's a wide range of answers that
you might get for this depending on the
department's maturity
i've been in a number of interviews
myself where the interviewer states that
they're
technology agnostic that is they don't
have their own official suite of tools
rather it could be more situational or
it's just based on whatever their client
wants
but in those instances those were very
up and coming data science departments
and they were just beginning to find
their footing and there's nothing wrong
with that because i was either totally
comfortable
or actively looking for a job just like
that
but it might not be what you're
personally looking for
maybe you want something that's a little
bit more structured like it's a
straight-up python shop
or something like that and i will say if
the org
claims to have a fully developed data
science process
but then they tell you that they're
completely technologically agnostic
that's a big red flag that they may not
be as organized as they tell you that
they are
which is a perfect segue to another
question you should ask
which is how do the various people who
work in different data roles
interact with and collaborate with each
other
so anybody who's been working on big
data projects for some time will tell
you
the various different data professionals
involved need to be
in close collaboration if not just tied
to the hip
in order for the project to be
successful some organizations have
cross-functional teams that work
together
using an agile framework and that's just
one example there's tons of different
ways that you can structure teams
now if you get just fuzzy details or
nothing at all here
that's a big time red flag the reason
being
there's lots of organizations out there
that just want somebody to be their
go-to person for everything data
or alternatively they have data problems
and their best solution for that is just
to throw different bodies at it
those situations are one-way tickets
toward
job dissatisfaction and frustration so
you want to avoid that
ideally there should be some kind of
structure in place that facilitates
people working together
and you'll also get a sense of maybe
they have data architects who curate the
data
then they pass it on to you then you
pass it on to some machine learning
engineer who puts your output into
production
or if all of that is on you and it's not
only that
the more collaboration that you have the
more opportunity there is to catch
mistakes
which do happen in data science and are
definitely not something that you want
all on you
and speaking of not wanting everything
to be all on you
another question you want to ask is what
sort of data infrastructure they have in
place
this is really going to demonstrate that
you're a comprehensive thinker
like i said there's way too many data
scientists who come out of school
and all they're focused on is
visualization and modeling
but experienced data professionals will
all tell you that what's far more
impactful to the quality of your output
is the quality of the data itself so
just asking this in the first place
demonstrates professionalism so if the
company doesn't have any sort of managed
infrastructure in place to support data
quality
this is another one of those things that
virtually guarantees
you're going to have a bad time you may
or may not
personally want to get involved in
building all the infrastructure
out yourself this is another one of
those things that depends on what kind
of data scientist
you want to be but if the organization
doesn't understand the hierarchy of
needs that underlie machine learning
or they don't know why that
infrastructure is important in the first
place
you want to run and you want to run fast
another question that i really like is
what's the plan for you for the next
three to six months
this is a big one right up front it's
one of those questions that really
demonstrates your enthusiasm and your
interest
but you also want to understand if
you're going to be working directly with
a client
or you're just going to be working
internally within the organization
but this is another one of those
questions that suppose if the
interviewer can't answer it coherently
then they might not really know what
they're doing with data science in the
first place
and the organization is pretty
disorganized you need to be coming on
for a pretty specific and well-defined
purpose that's easy to break down if not
well that's probably a red flag the
sixth thing that you should ask
is if the organization has any way of
supporting the continuous education of
data scientists
i think this is an incredibly fair one
to ask because right up front it
demonstrates that you're thinking in the
long term
and you're not just in it for a few
months i don't need to tell my
subscribers that
at least here in the united states
there's a lot of job hopping and jumping
ship after two to three years that
occurs
and at least with data scientists some
of this is due to stagnation that occurs
when you're doing the same thing over
and over again
for a year but meanwhile the field is
continuously evolving
so even to be forward looking to this in
the first place
is a proactive thing and it's a good
thing and being at the forefront and
understanding
what's happening in the field as it
evolves is good for your organization
because it is going to help you deliver
in a bigger and better way
there's a lot of things that this could
look like it could mean
funding conference attendance it could
mean paying for a semester of tuition
or for a coursera certification but i do
think at this point it is reasonable to
expect
something like this then here's one
final question that i learned a while
ago
and i recommend everybody ask regardless
of whether you're interviewing for any
kind of data capacity or not and that
question is
suppose you were to hire me what would
have to happen
such that in one to two years time
you and management are sitting around at
a table together and you're reflecting
on the time you hired me
talking about what a great decision that
was i love this question
this has the potential to flip the
entire nature of the interview on its
head
and maybe make the interviewers sit
there for a minute and have to thank
themselves and it's going to completely
illustrate what the organization's
expectations of you are
and to an extent how you're going to be
evaluated
and it also demonstrates that for you
delivering value
is the name of the game so ask this
question
i really think that it'll work for you
so we've gone through
seven different questions that i
recommend asking a data science job
interviewer
and i shouldn't have to say this but i
will say it
don't be a robot if they cover these
topics during the interview process
and you feel like you have a pretty good
handle on them there's probably no
reason to bring them up
unless you just want more clarity and
also don't rip these questions word for
word
be a human about it be organic they do
hire humans to work at data science jobs
at least for now
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you'd like to support my
work
please consider sharing this video also
smash the like button
and then leave me a comment down below
and let me know how your data science
job interview process was
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data